so I'm going to start today with the
total failure that was Donald Trump kim
jeong-hoon north korea summit number two
and to understand summit number two you
have to have some sense of the context
of summit number one and as a reminder
historically North Korean leaders have
been very interested in meeting with
American presidents and it's been the
American presidents who have been
uninterested in meeting with North
Korean leaders until and only if they
are willing to agree to some
preconditions because otherwise it would
be seen as a hugely valuable propaganda
accomplishment for the North Korean
leader without any sort of high
likelihood of achieving any change from
the point of view of American presidents
so when Donald Trump before the first
summit with Kim jong-un bragged that he
was able to secure a meeting with him it
exposed that Trump fundamentally knows
nothing about the history of North
Korean relationships because it's never
been a question whether an American
president would be able to meet with a
North Korean leader the question has
been under what circumstances should a
president agree to such a meeting and of
course not surprisingly after that first
summit in Singapore
Donald Trump came out saying a victory
there's no longer a nuclear threat from
North Korea here's a list of things that
the incredibly funny and smart and and
just great person Kim jong-un has agreed
to do and of course anyone who has been
an observer of the North Korea situation
for any period of time recognized that
it was the exact same vague promises
with no real plan for even observing
whether North Korea sticks to many of
them and as we now know nothing has
happened as a result of that first
summit Trump claimed victory but nothing
has actually changed and in fact we've
been reporting that there has been
continued activity and research and
development of weapon systems in North
Korea that's the set up okay that gets
us to the second summit over the last
couple of days last couple of days
adjusting for
very significant time zone difference in
Vietnam Trump by the way finally going
to Vietnam the bone spurs
notwithstanding he made it to vietnam
eventually but not until he was in his
70s and once again no progress and in
fact the negotiations were ended early
and some events were canceled
hilariously the White House schedule
actually planned for what they called a
joint agreement signing ceremony no
agreements sign so that event ultimately
it was cancelled Donald Trump reported
that Kim jong-un was demanding a total
removal of sanctions Trump saying well I
can't actually do that right now given
that you're not doing anything if Donald
Trump is telling the truth we will
listen to how he explained it and what
went down after talks failed and the
entire thing was ended on North Korea we
just left
chairman Kim we were really I think a
very productive time we thought and I
thought and secretary Pompeo felt that
it wasn't a good thing to be signing
anything I'm gonna let Mike speak about
it but we literally just left we spent
pretty much all day with kim jeong-hoon
who is he's quite a guy and quite a
character and I think our relationship
is very strong but at this time we had
some options and at this time we decided
not to do any of the options and we'll
see where that goes but it was it was a
very interesting two days and I think
actually it was a very productive two
days but sometimes you have to walk and
this was just one of those basically
they wanted the sanctions lifted in
their entirety and we couldn't do that
they were willing to denote a large
portion of the areas that we wanted but
we couldn't give up all of the sanctions
for that so we continue to work and
we'll see but we had to walk away from
that particular suggestion we had to
walk away from the okay so Donald Trump
correctly assessing that he can't just
lift all the sanctions a presidential
decision I agree with
finally of the Trump presidency how
funny though calling him quite a guy and
it was productive and the relationships
going great but yet this is a second
summit and literally nothing has come
out of it no progress no deal and
they're still developing missile sites
as of now we're told there's no plan for
a third summit so nothing substantive
other than Trump repeating that things
are going well and he has a great
relationship with Kim jong-un and he's
just an amazing guy now of course the
trumpets have their narrative for this
which is Trump's a tough negotiator
Trump went in there Kim jong-un wanted
something that Trump couldn't give an
end to all sanctions so Trump was the
tough guy and said no and that's a
perfectly fine narrative to try to craft
but it's a win for North Korea to meet
with an American president they've
always wanted to meet with American
president so going to Vietnam giving Kim
jong-un the photo-op which will be
propagandized within North Korea getting
nothing no progress it's a waste of time
it's a waste of money and it's a waste
of political capital for Donald Trump
and for the United States but the
trumpets don't seem to get it the one
opportunity that is to be taken
advantage of here is the possibility of
pressing Kim jong-un on human rights
issues which Donald Trump obviously
didn't do and why would he Donald Trump
admires the authoritarian dictator types
the White House hilariously unveiling a
commemorative coin for this big event
offering only a thousand of these coins
for $100 each to commemorate this great
day but they may have pulled this I went
on the White House gift shop website
this morning wasn't able to find the
coin maybe removed after the entire
thing flopped and the biggest failure if
I'm Trump what I see is the biggest
failure of this summit is not the lack
of an agreement with Kim jong-un it's
that it didn't even work to take
attention away from the Michael Cohen
testimony yesterday Donald Trump met
with Kim jong-un for hours yesterday and
there was almost no coverage in
corporate media other than to mention
that the talks broke down with no
progress all the focus on the Kohen
testimony as it should be Cohen
implicating
Donald Trump in multiple crimes it
failed to work even as a distracting
element in the news just a total and
complete failure once again